radar online says that the 82 year old
star wanted to be laid to rest in the
driver's seat of a 1977 Pontiac Trans Am
that of course was from Smokey and the
Bandit I can't get a second source on
this but it is an interesting story and
wouldn't put it past Burt Reynolds who
join us in November of 2015 and this is
how it sounded enough to join us this
morning Burt how are you very good we've
been telling stories here and oh well
never mind
goodbye what's the one story you're
asked about all the time over all of
them that's usually about women okay
let's start there no that's a good start
okay uh-huh and I've been very very
lucky Dinah Shore two years was the
classiest person I've ever met and I
hope I took a little bit of that with it
and I won't talk about the others okay
but back in the 70s if I if I hung out
with you in the 70s yes
you'd have been 11 no I would have been
about 14 but we still would have had fun
what would a weekend consisted of if we
hung out Burt Reynolds mid-70s if it was
a football game on we've watched that
and if it went to evening time I I'm not
going to put myself in a new set with
you okay but if we're watching football
well we have to watch Florida State
right yeah well of course yeah how good
were you at Florida State well you know
it's very difficult to talk about that
because I got hurt I was a start
starting a war game for games as a
freshman and I did well and then I came
back my sophomore year and
we even had the first game I hit my knee
and it went out and was going in all
different directions and it was most
painful part of my life I think how far
do you think you could have taken it if
you had stayed healthy oh you know you
can't if I predicted it they all say I
predicted it you know other people have
said nice things I I don't know I think
I could have certainly had some good
years of Florida State who knows what
would have happened after that did you
find acting or did it find you I I tell
you what happened I was going to the I
was going to the athletic department
every day to work out and after my knee
got hurt I I thought well hell I'm just
gonna have to find something else and I
walked across campus as far away from
the athletic department as I could go
and I saw some beautiful women and some
a lot of guys looked light in the
loafers and I thought maybe this would
be a good place to transfer so I went
over there and and it was wonderful I
had a great time and that's when I got
bitten by the bug when did you know
you'd sort of made it as an actor was
there one of those come into Hollywood
moments that you had no I don't think so
I I'd seen too many people go to
Hollywood and crash and burn and my
roommate was Rip Torn who was yeah not a
good person to discuss Hollywood with
but I loved him and he was people
they'll believe this but in the early
70s late 60s he was the hottest actor in
New York and I had a great time with him
and I'm still very very fond of him did
you know Clint Eastwood now there's a
story in the book you guys got fired on
the on the same day or let go from your
contracts on the same day
yes true in in you hung out with Clint I
did we were walking down the street to
his truck where he's gonna give me a
ride home and I said you're a hell of a
lot of trouble and he said why and I
said well they told you that your Adam's
apple stuck out too far and your tooth
is chipped and you know you talk to you
so and and I saw wasn't what have I done
and they said you can't act I said well
I can learn that actor but you can and
you can never get rid of that Adam
sample and it held him back and Sibley
as you can see did you know how big
deliverance was going to be when you
guys were shooting their movie I I
thought I was doing something very
dangerous I mean in terms of what we
were trying to do and that was the Zulu
mr. Dickies book and and I think we did
proud with it Ned Beatty should have won
an Academy Award he was brilliant it was
his first movie ever did and everybody
else John Boyd and I are friends for
life and see each other once a week and
Hollywood very proud of him what he's
done what's the movie that you stopped
and you watch when you're flipping
through the channels that you were in
that one deliverance would be yeah is
there one that's hard to watch which one
which one you say uh-oh all the full of
ones that I did before the seventies and
then after the seventies I just did it
because I was so flattered that I was
being offered these pictures that I took
something that I shouldn't have done and
I think probably beautiful goddesses
musicals that I had was a mistake
because
I can't sing and that's that is a
problem when you're doing musical
talking to Burt Reynolds the book is but
enough about me a memoir available
online and wherever books are sold
but Smokey and the Bandit but you have a
problem I know you did the remake
Longest Yard with Adam Sandler but would
you have a problem that if they did a
remake of Smokey and the Bandit with me
oh yeah if you I don't know if you want
to be in it no I wouldn't want the end I
would have to be a medically built to
bicycle I don't think I don't think they
take guys my age and has race but III
had a wonderful time and a wonderful
friends and it is it's a great race that
still goes on every year well you made
Trans Am cool - well Trans Am sales went
up 70% and I got a free Trans Am every
year of my life I was told by the
president I got one for three years one
didn't problem before here and I felt I
would really look like a jerk if I
called up and said where's my Trans Am
so I called up and said where's my Trans
Am and the man said let me get you to
the president I have talked to the
president I said maybe has been a
mistake in the shipping or something but
I was told by the president of Trans Am
at the time that I would get a free
Trans Am for life and I just was
wondering if there's a problem and he
said no there's no problem I just don't
like your movies and then would you say
I was nonplussed I didn't know what to
say there's nothing you can say so the
president if he doesn't like your films
except get a job how good was the movie
Boogie Nights for your career
considering when you did it and your
role in that that you got nominated for
an Oscar
[Music]
I was very hesitant about doing it and
turned him down I've got six times but
he kept coming back to the hotel and
pushing and pushing and pushing and
firing I blew up at it and he says you
know if you can blow up like that movies
are gonna get nominated for Oscar said
you just stick around and I will and he
did it and I was but you bet you read
the script mean even after you read the
scope you said no I don't want to do it
yeah I was I was concerned about the
about the people that were involved in
that discussion I wasn't I think it just
ruined woman's career obviously they
can't do anything else and not have it
being brought up and I know all about
things that have brought up ten years
after you do this I was also curious
when when you know we throw out sex
symbol now you were sex symbol back in
the 70s how difficult is that to deal
with that when you're labeled that well
it's very difficult to live up to when
you're dating when you're going with
somebody for a long time you you can
have a few laughs over I was little late
and it was just wonderful and very
understanding it did just it's just a
silly label that you can you know I
suppose you're George Hamilton and you
could love it
well even these guys now who get sexiest
man you know People magazine's sexiest
men man alive yes III don't think I ever
made that one he did not and I and I
like the fact you have a sense of humor
about the the Playgirl centerfold where
you said it was a little cold that day I
think it was a cosmopolitan so you're it
said it was a little cold that day yeah
was cold that day and I really resented
effect and I wanted the room heat is up
at the injure you should have demanded a
reshoot their bird you know have
somebody come in there and give me some
heat here please
well I I did ask them to bring in
something The Longest Yard role you more
number 22 which made you cool because
quarterbacks don't wear number 22 but
that was your goal no you know me right
you're not now you're old enough to know
better
my favorite quarterback was Bobby Lane
his number was 22 oh I like him off off
the field and on the field I thought it
was terrific
oh I thought that that was your jersey
number at Florida State it was okay but
okay that was for the same reason oh all
right
but did you do the football stunts did I
do the football
dalton's all the stunts in Longest Yard
yes every one of them and unfortunately
yeah we had four pro ball players on the
defense who wanted to play kill reactor
and the sorrow for the Green Bay Packers
Snitsky oh yeah ray tackled me one time
and we went out of bounds and I went
through the pensioners dance I said it's
just a movie and did he have his teeth
out his front teeth were very problem I
surprised there wasn't blood dripping
off there the book is but enough about
me a memoir Burt Reynolds Burt thank you
for joining us and good luck with the
book thank you Dan I'm a fan and you
tell my friends that if you keep doing
more movies with Adam Sandler I'm going
to ask Adam why I only did one do it
sounds sad to say or strange but I'll
put in a good word for you bird
it's not sad at all how about we do a
buddy film yes that's perfect you and me
back in the car we get the Bandit we get
we just we go across country I'm in if
you're in Burt all right there we go
well green like that great to talk to
you again bird thank you okay
god bless you dying Burt Reynolds well
late Burt Reynolds passed away yesterday
at the age of 82 but man sneaky sense
humor personality and you forget how big
he was like he was a big big big-time
star back in the 70s he's the real deal
and he looked great had that personality
there was an episode where he went on
The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson he
comes out and he's got all leather on
leather outfit black comes out he's got
whipped cream a canister of whipped
cream comes out and puts whipped cream
on Johnny Carson's time so these are two
of the biggest stars in America Johnny
Carson and then goes okay now they don't
say a word
he puts whipped cream on his tie crowds
going crazy Johnny then puts whipped
cream on Burt Reynolds outside of his
crotch and then Burt takes it and then
puts he splashes some some whipped cream
on Johnny's face Johnny then takes the
canister and then puts the whipped cream
down Burt Reynolds shirt just starts
spraying the whipped cream down there
Burt then no words are said and then
Burt takes the canister of whipped cream
and puts it down Johnny Carson's pants
so this is national TV granted late at
night Johnny takes the canister and then
puts it down Burt's pants and and then
Johnny grabs the canister and then tries
to put it down his pants and that ends
the bit there but no words were said
whatsoever but it was one of those
iconic moments but that's but that's who
Burt Reynolds was all about what he was
all about and you know Sandman had
nothing but great things to say about
working with him on the remake of
longest yard because I think he was
nervous he didn't know how Sam
was he Sandler didn't know how Burt
would react if you were gonna do a
remake but Sandler wanted to have Burt
in the movie and to be you know one of
the stars of the movie and pay tribute
to him so Burt Reynolds passed away at
the age of 82 for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]